Curious about glutathione? Should most breast cancer patients include this with their supplement regimen?
I would say no. So the pros and cons of glutathione. So glutathione is your main, your primary
intracellular inside the cell antioxidant. So you have processes of oxidation and antioxidation going
on in your body, extracellally, immediately outside the cell and intracellally inside the cell.
So the glutathione is your main intracellular antioxidant. It's made in the cell and it breaks down
oxidizing agents that enter into the cell. Now whenever you listen and read about oxidizing agents,
you think of them as poisons or bad guys, things that oxidize cells can cause cancer. So that's
true. So any poison or a toxin is an oxidizing agent and it is, it's cancer causing it can damage
cell membranes, it can damage the nucleus of the cell and if it damages the nucleus of the cell,
it can be a cause for cancer by oxidizing the amino acids in the DNA. It can damage the DNA.
So oxidizing agents can be damaging. However, there's a balance to that. Everything in physiology
has a balance. Your body actually makes reactive oxygen species for the purpose of killing biotoxins.
So when you have a biotoxin, let's say you have a bacteria or a virus,
your body will make reactive oxygen species to kill that virus or kill that bacteria.
So it's all about balance, so remember that. So I know we live in a world where you read a lot
about antioxidants and you should be taking a lot of antioxidants. Well, there may be truth to that.
Taking a lot of antioxidants can be helpful because we're exposed to so many oxidizing agents
and pesticides, chemicals, heavy metals, toxins, microtoxins, all these things are oxidizing agents.
So trying to balance out the amount of oxidizing agents that are damaging
their cell or have a potential of causing cancer with taking some extra antioxidants can be helpful.
However, if you're trying to kill cancer, you have to keep that balance that you're not using too
many oxidizing agents because sometimes your body uses reactive oxygen species to kill cancer cells.
That's exactly how chemotherapy works. Chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent and cancer cells
to be tend to be more prone to damage to oxidizing agents that a healthy cell does,
be partly because a healthy cell is healthy because the components of the cell are doing their job
and glutathione is a component that's recycled within the cell. So you don't actually need any
exogenous glutathione, a healthy person not exposed to excess oxidizing agents does not need to take
glutathione as a supplement. Why? Because glutathione is recycled inside the cell. It's oxidized
and reduced through a process of recycling inside the cell. So yeah, it does need the nutrients
in order to do that. And so, you know, taking some nutrients that can help that but
typically an average person would get that either diet as well. So why would a person take glutathione?
It's all because they're realizing that they're exposed to a lot of oxidizing agents so they want
to support the glutathione pathway. Why wouldn't a person take glutathione? If you're doing
chemotherapy, if you're doing another oxidizing agent, like there's different supplements that
are that kill cancer through the process of oxidization, protocell is one of those things. So you don't take
glutathione when you're taking protocell. And, you know, you got to keep that balance. I only tell
cancer patients to take glutathione if it tests on the cheek swab that it's okay for them to take it.
If you're reading my book, I'm not so positive on glutathione with cancer because you are, you know,
cancer, cancer cells are more prone to die through oxidation. And if you are, you could actually be
keeping cancer cells alive by taking glutathione. So I only tell people, I only recommend glutathione
with people that it tests well with otherwise I don't suggest glutathione. And I don't suggest
excess antioxidants with cancer patients unless it tests well. So lots of times in the natural world,
if you go to a natural path or a chiropractor or some natural doctor who's reading literature about,
you know, other health conditions. And then you have been a patient there. So now you get, you know,
you're going to diagnose a cancer and that person is helping you, but they don't really have a
specialty in cancer. They may put you on high dose antioxidants. And that might not be the right thing
to do. So there's some things that you would normally that could be helpful for you from a nutritional
standpoint. If you don't have cancer, and those same things might not be the right thing to take
if a person does have cancer. So it's a very long 10 minute answer to the question should most
breast cancer patients include this with their supplement regimen? The answer is no. And the reason
is that you may be keeping cancer cells alive by taking glutathione, or you may be counteracted
an oxidative therapy that you're doing either chemotherapy or some nutritional oxidative therapy.
So the answer to this, short answer is just no.